although lame-o's come to school
have a bat signal Aaron Riley is crazy
hot
you got the invite to his party tonight
right I notice you and I are listed in
the top 200 I think it's all political
oh my god he's coming over you're coming
to the party right we will definitely be
there
ah d-wave oldest it's all falling into
place
invited to Aaron Riley's party costume
figured out us for April
I'm betting sexy kitty which just leaves
my little brother Albert gross whatever
for once he's not my problem
oh no I forgot to tell you you're gonna
watch out for tonight no mom the party
don't do this to me love you thank you
you're welcome
this sucks I can't believe we're missing
the party it's Aaron a smiley face
emoticon that seals the deal run that is
how love works where's Albert my mom is
gonna kill me so Spidey just chilling
out here by herself you have any friends
or anything I'll tell you what I need a
man for a mission to avenge one broken
heart are you in take your time BAM
if we open your brother soon we're gonna
miss the party hey nerd alert hey guys
we need a car oh the thing is I can't
drive with anyone outside my immediate
social circle but we're friends uh
should go prostitution I know a place we
can ask 200 people if they've seen how
to really get all the hype about Aaron
well hey he's gorgeous and B please
refer to a I'm actually a worse parent
than my mom come on how much trouble
could he get into I want to put your
mask on you're about to be an accessory
to a major crime it's my duty to tell
you you are one step away from total
social suicide
quick retreat [ __ ] please see the
situation involving a musket and a
drumstick
I have this
I did not have it